En estas cuatro imágenes hemos representado
materia en diferentes estados, y hemos usado
lo que se conoce como modelo de partículas.
Estos son modelos de partículas bidimensionales,
son formas simples de imaginar lo que está
pasando a escala molecular dentro de la materia,
de modo que puedes imaginar cada uno de estos
círculos dependiendo de con qué estemos tratando,
como un ion, una molécula o un átomo. Nos dicen
cómo estas moléculas o iones o los átomos están
interactuando entre sí y eso determina el estado
en el que se encuentra la materia. Así que pausa
este video y piensa ¿cuál de estos cuadrantes
representa a la materia en estado sólido?, ¿cuál
representa a la materia en estado líquido? y ¿cuál
representa a la materia en estado gaseoso? Muy
bien. Puede ser que algunos de estos cuadrantes
te hayan resultado obvios, si imaginas que cada
uno de estos círculos es ion, podrías pensar que
estos son sólidos iónicos. Hemos visto ese tipo de
estructura reticular. Si imaginas que cada círculo
es un átomo que está formando enlaces covalentes
con círculos vecinos, entonces podrías imaginar
que esta es una red covalente sólida. Si imaginas
que cada uno de estos círculos es una molécula
y debido a las fuerzas intermoleculares se han
acomodado de esta manera regular con las otras
moléculas, entonces podrías imaginar que este es
un sólido molecular. También podrías imaginar
que cada uno de estos es un átomo de metal y
todos comparten los electrones de valencia, así
que estaríamos tratando con un sólido metálico.
Pero no importa qué opción imagines, es bastante
claro que es un sólido. Y una de las principales
características que vemos es que no está adoptando
la forma del contenedor, estas moléculas -supongo
que les podríamos llamar partículas- no son
capaces de deslizarse completamente una sobre
otra y tomar la forma del contenedor en el que
se encuentran, lo que sucedería en un líquido,
y claramente no pueden vencer las fuerzas entre
las partículas para luego salir y hacer lo suyo y
rebotar por todo el contenedor, lo que veríamos
en un gas, de modo que esto claramente es un
sólido. Ahora, en este cuadrante que tenemos
en la parte inferior izquierda parece que las
partículas están tomando la forma del contenedor,
son capaces de deslizarse una sobre otra,
pero todavía hay fuerzas intermoleculares que les
impide dispersarse. Claramente esto es un líquido.
Y en este cuadrante inferior derecho puedes
imaginar lo que está pasando: estas partículas,
ya sean moléculas o iones, en su mayor parte han
podido superar las fuerzas intermoleculares entre
ellas y están rebotando y tomando completamente
la forma del contenedor en el que se encuentran,
así que esto es un gas. Y ¿qué pasa con lo que
tenemos aquí? Se ve como un sólido porque no
está tomando la forma de su contenedor, pero
también es irregular de la forma que podrías
esperar de un líquido, al menos por un instante,
y como no está tomando la forma de su contenedor
y estas moléculas o estas partículas, a pesar de
que son irregulares no se deslizan una sobre otra,
como se esperaría en un líquido, esto también
es un sólido, pero lo llamamos sólido amorfo,
no tiene esta bonita estructura cristalina como
lo hemos visto con los sólidos cristalinos.
Hay muchos ejemplos de sólidos amorfos, la
mayoría de los sólidos que has visto en tu
vida y que son elásticos, que tienen una calidad
elástica, son los sólidos amorfos. Por ejemplo,
si tuvieras un pedazo de caucho natural podrías
estirarlo y podría verse así, pero luego,
al soltarlo, volvería a su estado original o casi
a su estado original. La razón por la que pasa
eso es porque el caucho natural está compuesto
de polímeros, y sólo para imaginar lo que es un
polímero aquí tenemos la estructura molecular del
caucho natural real, es una cadena de carbonos que
están unidos a hidrógenos, y si pudieras alejar
esta imagen podrías ver que todas estas largas
cadenas de carbonos con hidrógenos de caucho
natural se enredan entre sí y forman este sólido
amorfo. No se ve exactamente como este modelo
de partículas que acabamos de ver, es más como
un montón de cuerdas enredadas. Y si tuvieras que
tirar de ellas, podrían estirarse, pero después,
al soltarlas, volverían a estar así, como antes.
Ahora, lo interesante del caucho es que si tiras
lo suficiente estas cadenas en realidad pueden
alinearse de alguna manera y volverse un poco más
cristalinas, y entonces pierden sus propiedades
elásticas. Ahora, el caucho no es el único sólido
amorfo, los plásticos que ves a tu alrededor
también son sólidos amorfos, también son polímeros
como el caucho natural, lo que significa que son
moléculas formadas de unidades repetitivas. "Poli"
significa muchas, muchas unidades. De modo que
puedes imaginar que un plástico se compone de
estas unidades repetitivas. Estas largas moléculas
se encuentran unidas entre sí, y también hay casos
interesantes aquí. Por ejemplo, el vidrio que
la mayoría de nosotros supone que es un sólido,
porque parece que tiene las propiedades de
un sólido, no toma la forma de su contenedor,
se ve bien, se ve rígido. Estoy dibujando un
vidrio por aquí. En realidad resulta que si
tuvieras que mirar a nivel molecular verías que
es un sólido amorfo, no está tan bien organizado,
y estas moléculas se mueven lentamente una
al lado de la otra, pero a la mayor parte del
vidrio que tenemos ahora en el mundo moderno le
tomaría millones de años para que las moléculas
se deslizaran entre sí lo suficiente como para
notarlo. De modo que para todos los propósitos
deberíamos considerar que en realidad es un
sólido amorfo, al menos a temperatura ambiente.